in their 1934 paper Jordan Von Neumann
and wigner go on to conclude that the
structure of all such formerly real
finite and commutative R number systems
is fully determined it's shown that but
with one exception all such systems are
merely Matrix algebras they go on to say
that new results in contrast with the
present content of quantum mechanics are
to be expected only in this one
exceptional case this exception happens
to be the algebra of 3x3 hermitian
matrices with octonians as their entries
strange it's known as the exceptional
Jordan algebra also as the Albert
algebra it's a curious case in the
history of physics that this one
exception seems to have largely been
forgotten though it's been emphatically
rediscovered and studied some two
decades back researchers are now
investigating if this algebra might be
the correct way to describe the three
fermion generations of the standard
model of physics and if the eigenvalues
of the characteristic equation of this
algebra are key to understanding the
origin of fundamental constants this is
by the way the work of to Ginger Singh
and there are several other approaches
to using octions in physics which will
be covered later